[MUSIC PLAYING]
SPEAKER: Welcome to
the Click to Deploy
series, where we show you how
easy it is to deploy solutions
from Google Cloud Marketplace.
Google Cloud
Marketplace has been
focused on helping
users explore, launch,
and manage production-grade
solutions with just
a few clicks.
Marketplace has an easy way
to deploy technical solutions
called Click to Deploy.
Click to Deploy allows you
to deploy virtual machines
and Kubernetes solutions on
Google Compute Engine easily.
You can deploy a
solution without having
to manually configure the
software, virtual machine
instance, storage,
or network settings.
This helps you free
up more time to focus
on building great products.
You have the option
to deploy solutions
like WordPress, LAMP stack,
MongoDB, and Apache Cassandra.
With just the click of a button,
just search for the solution,
and select the ones that
meet your business needs.
When you launch
the deployment, you
can either use the
default configurations
or customize the configurations
to meet your project needs.
So next time you're
looking for a way
to quickly deploy your
solution, check out
Google Cloud Marketplace.
To learn more, check out
cloud.google.com/marketplace.